did you know there's a deadly fungus out  there that turns ants into zombies it's  known as the cordyceps fungus and  luckily it doesn't affect humans but  what if this fungus could somehow attack  you  if it did infect you you'd probably feel  some symptoms you've felt before things  like a fever weakness maybe even some  vomiting but as time went on the fungus  would start to take over your entire  nervous system since you're bigger than  an ant it would take months to fully  infect you but as it spread throughout  your arms and legs it would start to  gain control over you as it grew further  the infection would eventually kill you  and the cordyceps fungus would  eventually spread to the outside of your  body turning you into what's known as a  fruiting body the spores would then come  out of you and infect others starting  the process all over again  so